because I'm studying the limbic system
the amygdala and all these emotion
related areas it was a natural outgrowth
of that to start talking about disorders
in these models so it's not just about
successful filtering but also well what
what can go wrong as many ways the
things it could get can go wrong and
that allows us to not just ask what are
the correlates like which area is
involved but why so so so in the case of
schizophrenia it's again this circuit
involving the TR and this thin layer of
inhibit inhibitory neurons and the
thalamus and the cortex so we will just
focusing on what else we could say about
this free area circuit it's a it's a
generic circuit so for different systems
you have the same kind of motif we call
it a circuit motif and so schizophrenia
is very complicated disorder and no one
has really found a definitive cause or
even a definitive correlate but in
recent years one line of research
experimentalists have uncovered is
dysfunctional inhibition so there's
local inhibition in the cortex and
tamping things down and there's the TR
and itself which has been linked with
schizophrenia so so we thought let's
look at this circuit and see what it can
do and what can go wrong
so when you're making a computational
model you need to fix a behavior that is
tractable like modeling hallucinations
would be cool but it's very difficult
because you know we really don't
understand how language is generated so
getting to that is is too complicated so
what we found I I was quite intrigued to
learn that a few years ago that one of
the most readily identifiable symptoms
of schizophrenia is disordered eye
movements so schizophrenia patients and
sometimes their close relatives have an
inability to fix their eyes on a target
and for instance you could have a dot on
a screen that's moving around and and
healthy controls they can follow along
that dart just fine like going in a
figure of eight for instance whereas
with schizophrenia patient
there their eyes will often be quite
erratic and there was a paper showing
that a machine learning method involving
a couple of eye movement tasks just
using those could tell schizophrenia
patients and their close relatives from
controls with something like above 95%
accuracy so it's a diagnostic symptom
very useful for you know at-risk
populations and for the patient's
themselves and so the question is well
what's producing this this symptom and
might that shed light on other symptoms
so I set up a circuit involving a
simplified version of the the three
brain needs in the cortex trm thalamus
and I made a simple eye tracking model
that that uses the this kind of circuit
to maintain a target at the center of
attention and what we saw is that these
disrupting a couple of different classes
of inhibition could produce this erratic
behavior and so so so that's something
that experimentalist can now maybe work
with we showed that different inter
disruptions could look vaguely similar
but also have differences so this ties
into the idea that schizophrenia and
potentially other disorders may not just
be one disorder they may be a family of
disorders with different causes that
seem outwardly similar and I think this
is very important going forward for the
field and I think the field is more and
more acknowledging this so apart from
that diversity of causes story one idea
that we elaborate in the discussion
section is is the idea that going
off-track is maybe a feature of other
symptoms of schizophrenia
so one symptom is having disordered
thoughts so it may be that if you can't
track a dot some if that similar
disruption is going on elsewhere it's
you're not able to follow the context
relevant set of thoughts so the same
disruption going on in an analogous
circuit might prevent up someone from
holding onto Earth
the line of thinking and sort of jumping
from one thing to the other so it's an
interesting way of looking at how a
simple local circuit disruption can have
these widespread effects in different
systems
okay this example was Nam thinking my
imaginations roaring about all these
other potential diagnostic methods that
don't yet exist that were so good that
we're gonna be able to figure out and
leverage machine learning to be able to
more effectively figure it out thank
bomb and then also when you're when
you're explaining this potential that
that something as complex as a
schizophrenia could potentially be a
myriad of different involvement in
different brain regions and very
complicated and this is all the way to
when humans even in the womb and then
they're born and like there's you know
the foundational infrastructures that
get laid out at during that time period
and how that interplays with their
adolescent and adult like Zeca thing
okay I have I have a question pre as we
get into depression I want to ask about
schizophrenia
I've had several conversations with
people about how we may all be this
spectrum of schizophrenia potential from
a good schizophrenia to a bad
potentially schizophrenia and how in at
in and what what we've created with
hyper realities where it like a Santa
Claus it's kind of like a hyper reality
we've made up a story okay and we call
it real and then people tell some people
tell their kids that that's real yeah
there's cookies and stuff and sliding
down the chimney with presents and
almost of reindeer etc and and then it
almost gets you know in a sense there's
these two competing realities right are
they marrying and so
Oh for and and some people even say one
of the most potentially one of the
greatest measurements of of intelligence
is one's ability to abstractly reason
multiple perspectives multiple variables
on a on a given issue and so when you're
doing that what you're doing is you're
trying to see how like a low
socioeconomic status person sees the
world how a rich person sees the world
how someone from India of someone from
Pakistan how someone from different
countries also different genders
different religions how people see the
world right so if you're trying to
balance all these perspectives and see
them all so do you see kind of where I'm
coming that in this term and how do you
feel about all of that so I just started
leading a book sort of from left field
compared to the neuroscience side it's
called the sublime object of Psychiatry
it's a kind of a moral humanities
approach to schizophrenia so it
describes schizophrenia as a sublime
object and what they mean by that is it
schizophrenia has been defined by
various fields including biological
psychiatry and psychoanalysis as sort of
beyond understanding meaning that you
could maybe study it but you can never
empathize with the schizophrenia patient
it's a very strange book but very
interesting because I have and you know
people can relate to this they're like
yeah the first when the schizophrenia
patient is describing their
hallucinations or their overarching
world theory you can kind of make sense
of parts of it but the whole thing you
just very hard to understand what's
going on with that person so if what if
I understand what you're saying
correctly perhaps some of these people
are kind of torn between so many
perspectives that they end up with this
mosaic idea that that is a product of
perspectives that don't even sit well
together it's a fun speculation but you
know when you're talking about disorders
that you have to remember there's a lot
of suffering involved in this there and
so if you wouldn't wish this on anyone
and especially the psychosis side of
things and catatonia and then there is
also a way to cook to as one potentially
experience as a psychosis from this
mosaic of worldviews and say there is a
way to live with that in a gentle way in
a way that creates almost a deeper
degree of empathy for four different
worldviews in that sense and so although
it can at times feel like it's a big
taking on the burdened to be able to
relate to all these different worldviews
at the same time it it makes one super
well-rounded and in that sense but so
it's a good another way to view this is
just the way that we use the social
media culture because when you take a
look at people's profiles it's it's it's
only almost exclusively their best
selves and so then that becomes you know
what's real in this sense what is
actually you because is you really only
your photos of you looking your absolute
best traveling having the best meals the
best people is it real no yeah so
because you're definitely not posting
when you feel anxiety or when you feel
depressed or when you you know you're
feeling a lack of love or you know so so
here's again this this this idea of what
is reality and how can how do hyper
realities how do balancing different
worldviews into a large mosaic how do
these things relate to schizophrenia
it's a fascinating question if we're in
a simulation or not these are very very
hard questions but what you said about
empathy I think can help we may be
ground this in something so I read a few
years ago a fascinating paper on
schizophrenia in different cultures so I
believe it was called hearing voices in
I think Africa in Ghana and Jena it was
an African city in an Indian city excuse
me
and the I discovered it through a blog
called neuro anthropology which so the
point of the paper was that it's widely
believed that schizophrenia is a fairly
universal disorder affecting around one
percent of people worldwide but the
specific manifestations of it can be
quite different so meaning the content
of the hallucinations is different so um
in different parts of the world like for
instance apparently in the West and in
America a lot of the voices are
potentially giving sort of violent
instructions of some sort
whereas apparently in India some the
voices sometimes are a motherly voice
telling you to clean up your room so so
there's that difference then there's
also the way in which society responds
to the person having hallucinations so
the paper talked about how in certain
tribes they frame this having of
hallucinatory voices in terms of
possession so a spirit is possessing you
and interestingly you might think well
that's unscientific it's nonsense but it
this may actually help reintegrate
people into society because when the
person is not hearing voices are acting
weird their belief is well they can come
join work because the spirit isn't with
them today and allowing people to be in
society and be a productive member of
society is really important and one of
the things you read for instance in that
book I mentioned earlier is that
schizophrenia is sometimes defined in
terms of inability to contribute to
useful work so there's a capitalist
element to who we decide is like
incapable of being useful so the way
that society there's one sense because
if you give them a big paint kit well
you know I often wonder if you know in
you know this is a popular idea that in
early generations people who were
prophets or maybe shaman might have been
what we would now call schizophrenia
patients so
so how the culture responds is important
and also how they tell people so for a
long time in America there was an
instruction to patients to ignore the
hallucinations where as what you said
about empathy is very relevant because
some places they instruct patient
patients to listen to their not act on
everything that the voice tells them to
do if they're telling saluting but you
could in the spirit of empathy towards
people outside these constructed people
that may exist in new are in a sense
perspectives they might not be correct
or accurate yes but as with most people
people just want to be heard and and
given some kind of consideration you
don't have to list act on every piece of
advice you receive but giving them the
time to be heard is a great way to
diffuse frustration and tension rather
than ignoring people yes so so so
empathy towards oneself may be important
to one's selves yeah yeah yeah this is
this isn't such a fascinating back and
forth on on schizophrenia and I really
am so interested in it